[Musica]
quante volte vi sarà capitato
magari durante una passeggiata in
montagna oppure al mare all'alba seduti
sulla spiaggia di chiudere i vostri
occhi
e di lasciarvi andare
e di immaginare cosa c'è oltre cosa c'è
oltre un bosco oltre una vetta oltre gli
scogli
la nostra immaginazione ha un potere
straordinario potrebbe portarci ovunque
in qualsiasi parte del mondo
in realtà il video che vedete qui sono
proprio il frutto dell'immaginazione
ma di un'immaginazione un po speciale
che è l'immaginazione degli algoritmi
questi video infatti sono stati
realizzati da un algoritmo di
intelligenza artificiale
sviluppato quest'anno da alcuni
ricercatori americani di google
questo algoritmo consente data
un'immagine una qualsiasi immagine di un
paesaggio di generare un video
estremamente realistico dando la
sensazione che la telecamera si muove in
aria come su di un drone il risultato lo
vedete anche voi è impressionante
in realtà vi dirò questo è solo un
esempio di quello che riusciamo a fare
oggi in intelligenza artificiale
nell'ambito della generazione delle
immagini e dei video e oggi vorrei
raccontarvi proprio questo vorrei
parlarvi di come noi ricercatori
insegniamo agli algoritmi ad immaginare
mi occupo di intelligenza artificiale da
ormai 15 anni in particolare studio la
visione artificiale
inglese computer vision il computer
vision studiamo gli algoritmi che
consentono alle macchine di vedere che
consentono alle macchine di analizzare
di estrarre informazione dalle immagini
e dai video
quando ho cominciato a lavorare in
computer vision mi occupavo di
sviluppare degli algoritmi per
analizzare immagini del fondo oculare e
aiutare così i medici a diagnosticare
una grave patologia che è la retinopatia
diabetica
oggi a distanza di qualche anno di pochi
anni abbiamo diverse soluzioni
commerciali che supportano i medici
nella diagnosi della retinopatia
diabetica
e tre anni fa life gay l'ente regolatore
americano ne ha persino approvato l'uso
nella pratica clinica
questo per dirvi è solo un esempio di
come la computer vision va veloce dei
progressi che sono stati fatti in questi
anni in questa disciplina
in effetti se ci penso
potrei dire di aver assistito a tanti
progressi e potrei dire di avere
assistito a due vere e proprie
rivoluzioni
oggi vorrei raccontarvele
la prima rivoluzione è stata quando
circa una decina di anni fa il deep
learning gli algoritmi basati sulle reti
neurali hanno fatto irruzione in
computer vision
le reti neurali molti di voi ne avranno
già sentito parlare
tenerti neurali nascono da un'idea
ambiziosa
intrigante che è quella di creare dei
modelli
computazionali
che mirano ad emulare il comportamento
della rete di neuroni che abbiamo
all'interno del nostro cervello
in effetti una rete neurale e fatta da
tanti nodi strettamente interconnessi
organizzati su più livelli proprio come
i nostri neuroni e grazie a questa
struttura una rete neurale è in grado di
imparare è in grado di apprendere da
grandi moli di dati
questo significa che se diamo ad una
rete neurale milioni e milioni di
immagini di oggetti e diciamo alla rete
per ogni immagine l'oggetto contenuto in
essa la rete sarà un grado dopo il suo
addestramento di dirci data una nuova
immagine mai vista prima questa immagine
contiene questo oggetto
grazie al dip learning
di strada ne abbiamo fatta tanta grazie
al dip learning oggi siamo riusciti a
risolvere tutta una serie di problemi
che prima non riuscivamo ad affrontare
grazie al dip learning oggi abbiamo a
disposizione tecnologie che ci
consentono di trovare veicoli pedoni in
scene di traffico complesse e ci aiutano
a creare i sistemi a guida autonoma
grazie al dip learning oggi abbiamo a
disposizione tecnologie che ci
consentono dato un'immagine una
qualsiasi immagine presa dal web di
calcolare di generare in automatico una
descrizione del suo contenuto e questo
ci aiuta in tantissime applicazioni
anche per sviluppare tecnologie di
ausilio a persone ipovedenti
potrei continuare con questi esempi a
lungo ma oggi vorrei raccontarvi della
seconda rivoluzione
la seconda rivoluzione è stata quando
qualche anno dopo
siamo stati in grado di creare delle
macchine che immaginano non solo delle
macchine che vedono siamo stati in grado
di creare degli algoritmi che generano
nuovi contenuti nuovi dati nuove
immagini e siamo stati in grado di farlo
grazie un tipo di rete neurale che se ti
chiamano reti neurali generative
come è fatta una rete neurale generativa
eccola questa è una rete neurale
generativa si chiama gun generative
adversarial network una gamma è fatta in
realtà da due reti che competono
da due reti antagoniste la prima rete
il generatore allo scopo di generare
oggetti complessi nel nostro caso
immagini di volti la seconda rete il suo
oppositore il discriminatore cerca di
scoprire se un immagine è stata generata
dal generatore o è un'immagine reale
durante il processo di addestramento
queste due reti competono perché ognuna
di esse cerca di migliorare le sue
prestazioni e alla fine di questa
competizione
quello che succede è che il generatore
ha imparato a generare delle immagini
sempre più simili alle immagini di
partenza delle immagini reali
guardatele nessuno di questi volti è
reale sono tutti sinteticamente generati
da un aggancio da una rete generativa
ma c'è di più
le reti neurali generative ci consentono
di esplorare i dati possiamo immaginare
di riempire uno spazio multidimensionale
detto spazio latente con dati su milioni
e milioni di volte ogni immagine può
essere rappresentata dalle sue
caratteristiche il colore degli occhi il
colore dei capelli la forma del viso e
ognuna di queste caratteristiche è una
dimensione in questo spazio
multidimensionale in questo spazio
latente
immagini simili vengono mappate in punti
vicini in questo spazio e possiamo
muoverci ed esplorare i dati muoverci in
questo spazio e generare infinite
combinazioni di volti il nostro spazio
multidimensionale il nostro spazio
latente ci consente di creare ci
consente di immaginare
quando
abbiamo cominciato a capire il
potenziale
delle reti neurali generative a trento
nel mio laboratorio
abbiamo cominciato a farci delle domande
e abbiamo cominciato a chiederci ma fin
dove possiamo spingerci
con questo processo generativo
possiamo per esempio pensare di generare
dei video e non solo delle immagini
statiche
oppure possiamo dato un video pensare di
modificarlo come vogliamo oppure
possiamo rendere l'utente protagonista
di questo processo di generazione
la risposta è sì a tutte queste domande
possiamo per esempio creare delle reti
neurali generative
sentono di generare video i cosiddetti
dfx
questi video sono stati generati da un
algoritmo sviluppato nel nostro
laboratorio di ricerca questo algoritmo
prendere ingresso un video in questo
caso il video del mio volto e una serie
di immagini statiche
e comincia ad animarle i risultati sono
dei video sintetici con movimenti
estremamente naturali proprio come
vedete qui anche nel caso della statua o
della bambolina
riusciamo a farlo chiedendo alla nostra
rete neurale di modellare non solo
l'informazione legata all apparenza ma
anche l'informazione legata al movimento
e riusciamo a farlo non solo per i volti
ma per qualsiasi altro oggetto e
riusciamo a farlo in tempo reale il che
significa che tecnologia di questo tipo
oggi possono essere integrate in
numerosi sistemi ad esempio nei sistemi
di video chiamata
ma possiamo fare di più possiamo anche
creare degli algoritmi che ci consentono
di generare dei video realistici ma
sintetici modificando solo una parte del
volto come ad esempio i capelli o la
regione degli occhi oppure solo una
parte del corpo come per esempio la
regione del corso ho le gambe
possiamo fare ancora di più possiamo
rendere l'utente al centro di questo
processo di generazione
e possiamo creare degli algoritmi che
data un'immagine una qualsiasi immagine
generano dei video giocabili come se
fossero dei videogames
questo significa che se per esempio
prendiamo un immagine di un campo da
tennis
siamo in grado con il nostro algoritmo
di generare un video realistico e
l'utente può partecipare a questo
processo di generazione e muovere il
giocatore ad esempio affinché colpisca
la palla
possiamo anche creare dei modelli che
integrano diversi tipi di dato
le immagini il testo la musica
all'interno dello stesso processo di
apprendimento
possiamo quindi generare immagini dal
testo musica da un video questo è quello
che succede ad esempio se chiediamo ad
uno di questi modelli di tradurre la
frase il colosseo sulla luna in questo
video
il risultato finale
lo vedete è un immagine onirica
pazzesco
negli anni le gang i modelli generativi
non sono stati utilizzati soltanto per
generare immagini in video sono stati
utilizzati per generare musica per
generare poesie articoli giornalistici
illustrazioni fumetti opere d'arte
queste opere d'arte sono state
realizzate da un software che si chiama
che hai creative network sviluppato da
alcuni ricercatori americani
queste opere d'arte hanno riscosso un
successo incredibile sono state esposte
nelle o nelle gallerie d'arte di tutto
il mondo e alcune di esse sono state
persino vendute all'asta
è ormai chiaro a tutti non solo agli
esperti di intelligenza artificiale
che queste tecnologie
generative hanno raggiunto un potenziale
elevatissimo
non vi nascondo che
molti hanno perplessità preoccupazione
ma io credo che queste tecnologie
rappresentino anche un potenziale
incredibile
un potenziale incredibile per
l'industria cinematografica per la moda
per l'industria creativa per la
formazione
oggi
designer artisti sono in grado di creare
grazie all'intelligenza artificiale in
un modo nuovo più efficiente
possiamo immaginare che in futuro sempre
più artisti creeranno insieme
all'intelligenza artificiale
proprio come dovreste vedere qui ma
in futuro le aziende di moda
utilizzeranno
l'intelligenza artificiale per creare
campagne personalizzate
in futuro noi avremo a disposizione
sempre più tecnologie che ci
consentiranno di
indossare gli abiti che abbiamo scelto
sul web virtualmente a casa nostra
in futuro gli insegnanti gli educatori
potranno
utilizzare i deep fake per creare
materiale sempre più coinvolgente per le
loro lezioni e ci faranno raccontare la
storia direttamente dai suoi
protagonisti
a questo punto alla fine di questo talk
viene spontaneo chiederci ma stiamo
creando degli strumenti che ci
potenziano in quanto esseri umani
creativi o che ci sostituiscono
io credo che la mente umana sia l'unica
macchina realmente creativa realmente in
grado di creare cose nuove
credo anche però che non dobbiamo avere
paura non dobbiamo chiudere le porte
all'intelligenza artificiale
se ci pensate da sempre noi utilizziamo
la tecnologia per andare oltre i nostri
limiti biologici abbiamo creati
telescopi per potenziare la nostra vista
gli aerei per volare gli smartphone per
potenziare le nostre capacità di
comunicare a distanza
oggi possiamo utilizzare l'intelligenza
artificiale per potenziare le nostre
capacità creative e allora facciamolo e
utilizziamo l'intelligenza artificiale
per creare cose che non avremmo mai
immaginato prima
picasso diceva
tutto ciò che possiamo immaginare è
reale
e io credo che come vi ho mostrato oggi
il confine tra realtà e immaginazione
grazie all'intelligenza artificiale sta
diventando davvero sempre più labile
grazie
[Applauso]